real question is are you going to want
to perform in Australia well that's the
question we've been getting isn't it
like now that we've done a tour in
America I'm assuming your parents are
going to go to that right I mean I
assume so unless my dad's like no can't
be
[__] I don't think they'll say that
though do a one-off show in
Australia one point yeah again like the
biggest question we've been getting now
that we finished the European tour is
like well Asia tour next if that's the
case we have to go to Australia I think
uh we'd have to figure out I we kind of
figured out in EUR the Europe tour how
much harder Logistics was compared to
America yeah we should like the merch
cuz you can't travel with merch across
borders otherwise you pay taxes yeah so
you have to get it delivered and
obviously when you're as you all know if
you've ever lived in Europe deliveries
are not uh Reliant or reliable at all
one one of the shows the the merch guys
[__] up and we almost weren't able to
sellmark no it was uh rdale yeah
Rotterdam or Amsterdam I can't remember
maybe it was
Denmark the mer didn't show up till
after the show yes that's right because
one of the drivers of the delivery
company missed the shipment uh so our
our [__] team I actually like I want
to Big it up to our team who were
[__] goated and sorted out somehow so
professional so they hired someone to
take seven or 10 or something a
ridiculous amount a 17
boxes of merch on a
plane to amster no no to Denmark sorry
um so we can get to our show on time cuz
we were this close to not having like
any merch of that show yeah cuz that's
how how you kind of make a lot of the
shows profitable and make sense to do
because a lot of the times that's how
I'm sure you all know if you've watched
music That's How B make most of their
money yeah and uh they somehow managed
to make it happen uh and that wasn't
even like one of the most impressive
things cuz we found out uh I think 3
days before our Cardiff show that our
venue had oh that had just closed it
just closed it was so funny so I was
sitting on the bus and I I haven't used
the BBC News app in a long time cuz it
they changed it and the layout of it is
now [__] and so I stopped using it
because it was so annoying to navigate
yeah and for some reason I was on the
back of the bus and we were in we were
on our way to the Berlin show and I uh
and the the uh one of the tour staff was
in the back with us uh and I was just
scrolling on it and I saw this news
article that said and it was posted 2
minutes ago it was like St David's hall
closed in Wales and I was like huh
that's sure sounds like the venue that
we're performing in but but the poster
real quick but St David's in Wales
that's everywhere St he's like our only
dude so I was like well let's have a
look where it is it's like St David's
haul in Cardiff I was like huh maybe
there's two halls in Cardiff cuz we're
having a show in a few days there's no
way it's closing yeah and then I look up
online I was like oh oh y That's our
venue it's closed and the reason why
it's was closed is because in the UK
right now there's this whole thing where
there there's a big scare going on
because some buildings used air rated
concrete which I'd never heard of until
this which my god
um UK construction man I
mean of course we would use that because
we we also use like an ungodly amount of
asbestos as well yeah so so what so what
why measure cheaper I obviously if you
use less concrete and that it's air
rated it's cheaper but it's also more
brutal it's ridiculous yeah so the venue
was shot and I can't I think I think it
was a brief moment when we all thought
oh well I guess the tour is finishing in
London yeah yeah cuz it just seemed like
it was logistically impossible to get a
show in Wales we had three days to find
and set up a new venue which is like
normally an impossible cuz you know we
we had venue that was 1,200 yeah and
there's you can't just transfer that
size but I think luckily we we'd sold
less tickets which is normally not a
lucky thing but it worked out that we
could find another venue last minute uh
and and yeah the university right
students union which was kind of fun cuz
it was actually like a really cozy venue
it we were really close to the audience
even though there was 700 people there
totally it it was a nice turn off to the
show it was a nice like
Vibe going back to UNI everyone in Wales
was super
nice big up to my my Walsh viewers uh
you guys were by far and it was and I
mean you had some good competition but
everyone was super super polite totally
totally like I was going in and out of
the venue a lot and people were like oh
hi Connor and they would just be like oh
have a nice day and they' hold the door
open for me and stuff and I was like
dude what the heck not that like um it's
just cuz like sometimes we were running
and being rushing and I feel bad when I
going to be like I can't I can't stop
and talk I'm sorry they're like oh go
ahead see you super good good was boys
boys one one thing I found funny when we
were in Wales actually is when we went
to H Cardiff uh Cardiff
Castle and there was one super proud
Welshman there just like telling us the
history uh because we were talking about
how we were performing and our venue had
like closed down due to structural
issues and he was talking about well you
should have just [__] performed here
you know Castle yeah he's been like
we've
we've been invaded by the English the
Romans we've been invaded so many times
they kicked our ass and we're still here
and they're
like most Welsh thing I've ever
[Music]
heard and I'm like What's the cap of
this place like 20 I I realized how I
don't come across as well at all cuz
people kept asking me they're like is
your first time in Wales really yeah and
all the stores I went to and I was like
no I guess it's because you've got lost
your accent I well I never had a wsh
accent but I don't sound wsh and I was
like yeah no I I well she's like oh cool
like like I think I I actually s of the
one store clerk and I got I knew right
away she thought I was doing that
American thing where like you say like
oh no I'm like I'm Irish oh I'm 1 18
Welsh 100% was I knew she was thinking
that cuz the way that she responded to
me like oh that's nice and I was like no
I didn't say anything El but I my head I
was like no I speak the language America
pill I'm I'm Welsh was should again you
know what I will say I do enjoy
traveling especially to European
countries with Americans because they
are so like they are so easily impressed
oh my God and it was Jess Jesse our tour
manager everywhere she went she was just
brigh eyed like she was like I [__]
love it here like I am so jealous of
their energy cuz you know growing up in
English is like yeah it's a it's a
[__] Castle we got so many of Castle
yeah yeah and every time they'd see
anything in Europe it's just like oh my
God that's so
amazing like like we were we were we
were walking around Copenhagen uh and
our tour manager was so [__] enamored
with like this European city with
Copenhagen that uh we went to I believe
like another Castle there or something
uh and there was this uh Danish like
guard like you know one of the
traditional Danish guards there and uh
he was just like marching like he had he
had a gun uh which he was like carrying
this gun like a baby I've never seen
someone handle a gun so delic of this
Danish yeah and uh he was just he was
just like marching uh across like the
castle uh and I to manager goes oh my
God just look at the way he walks he
puts One Foot In Front of the other foot
it's just it's just amazing and I'm like
Jesse that's just typically how people
walk you just describe
walking oh wow they look they look like
British on yeah no they do what the [__]
where did they steal off this this guy
was like hugging this [__] like AK
yeah and it was it was crazy
akt standard issue in it was like a
semi-automatic like it was a gun we
don't know our guns again just said AK I
don't think it was an AK what was it I
know what it was it was a big gun yeah
uh yeah I mean it's it's kind of it's
got to be really cool seeing how you
travel a few hours and it's a completely
different culture I mean I think I think
one thing that I've always always felt
and one thing I've always kind of try to
explain is that I think the vastness of
America is lost on Americans a lot of
the time too it's so big and you and
it's really hard to appreciate that
there are differences in America but I
think just because of how kind
of you you all are so insular yet so
separated at the same time like the fact
that it's a six-hour flight from one
side of America to the other is insane
yeah it's such it's such a large country
uh but that being said when you go to
Europe and you're like I drove an hour
and there a different country and
different culture and different language
it's it's so it's got to be such a
freaky for me for me the concept of just
driving to another country is so foreign
to me oh Australia cuz Australia and
Japan can't do that [__] you know yeah
so it was really cool just like you know
cuz I thought it was cool like on the
first America Tour where it was just
like oh cool we're in like a different
state you know I just [__] fast
travel to another city when this one it
was like I just fast travel to another
country yeah and that was like wild make